ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen es
fehlt an Waffen die Soldaten sind
ausgelaugt der Winter ist unbarmherzig
und die internationale Hilfe stockt wie
kritisch ist die Lage in der Ukraine
darüber sprechen wir gleich mit dem
Militärexperten Nico lange hier in der
Sendung schreibt uns gerne wie immer
eure Fragen und Kommentare an die
eingeblendete E-Mailadresse
zdfheute-live@zdf.de oder in die
Kommentare das russische Militär hat
heute diese Bilder veröffentlicht einen
artilleriekampfeinsatz zu sehen sind
unter anderem die Besatzungen
verschiedener Mörser und Haubitzen die
ukrainische Stellungen beschießen
Geländegewinne gibt es offenbar kaum
weder für die russischen Angreifer noch
für die ukrainischen
Verteidiger bevor wir zu unseren
Korrespondenten in die Ukraine und nach
Moskau schalten begrüße ich hier Nico
lange bei uns im Stream schon oft zu
Gast gewesen jetzt auch wieder
zugeschaltet aber Herr Lange für alle
die die Sie noch nicht kennen stelle ich
sie kurz vor sie waren oder sie sind
militäranalyst bei der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz dre Jahre lang in
führender Position im
Verteidigungsministerium sie waren mal
Leiter des Büros der Konrad Adenauer
Stiftung in Kiev und davor
wissenschaftlich und forschend tätig in
Russland Herr Lange wie kritisch ist
denn die Lage in der Ukraine aus ihrer
Sicht und die Lage ist schon seit
einiger Zeit schwierig weil die
ukrainische Gegenoffensive nur
Teilerfolge erreicht hat und weil jetzt
zumindest in einigen Frontabschnitten
Russland wieder versucht anzugreifen
aber die Lage ist gleichzeitig ganz
sicher nicht so schlimm und so doom and
glom wie das manchmal in den Debatten
den einschein hat also wir müssen da
auch aufpassen dass wir uns da nicht in
so eine Untergangsstimmung reinreden die
Ukraine wird sicherlich aber jetzt ganz
genau
dahinucken wo die Entscheidungen
getroffen werden für die weitere
Bereitstellung von Ressourcen weil das
ja schon ein Unterschied macht ob man
sich darauf verlassen kann dass weiter
Munition und Ausrüstung kommt oder wenn
es damit Schwierigkeiten geben könnte
dazu gibt's ein paar Zahlen die das
Institut für Weltwirtschaft IfW in Kiel
veröffentlicht hat und die sehen für die
Ukraine nicht gut aus demnach sind
Militär und Finanzhilfen von August bis
Oktober im Wert von 2,11 Milliarden Euro
zugesagt worden das ist nur etwas mehr
als ein Zehntel der Summe aus dem
Vorjahreszeitraum und der niedrigste
Stand seit Januar
2022 wie dramatisch ist das für die
Ukraine na das kann man noch nicht sagen
ob das dramatisch ist die Realität sieht
ja so aus dass jetzt ja immer noch die
Lieferungen ankommen die schon im
letzten Jahr oder vor einiger Zeit
zugesagt worden sind z.B die Leopard 1
aus Deutschland oder andere Systeme also
das wenn es einen Effekt gibt von keinen
neuen zusagen dann wird der mit
Zeitverzögerung eintreten nicht sofort
aber sicherlich ist es vor allen Dingen
nicht gut dass die
Produktionskapazitäten nicht erhöht
worden sind z.B bei Artilleriemunition
das scheint mir eins der dring Probleme
zu sein und da muss die Ukraine jetzt
schon mit den Ressourcen Haushalten das
ist ganz sicher ein Problem das viel
Aufmerksamkeit erfordert und wo es gut
wäre wenn wir die lösen die
Unterstützung für die Ukraine ist ja
nicht nur militärisch sie ist auch
finanziell und humanitär und ich glaube
in allen Bereichen sind jetzt große
Anstrengungen erforderlich insgesamt
kann man ja beim Trecker in Kiel aber
auch sehen dass die Bedeutung der
Europäer gewachsen ist und es wäre gut
wenn sich diese Tendenz noch verstärkt
dass die Europäer stärker die Ukraine
unterstützen wenn in den USA da im
Moment sehr schwierige innenpolitische
Diskussionen dazu geführt werden hier
kommt jetzt eine konkrete Frage nach
Lieferungen ein usernern namens Dieter
fragt würde die Lieferung von Taurus
einen spürbaren Unterschied am
Frontverlauf machen oder nicht so wie es
Pistorius
behauptet die Ukraine braucht gerade
einige Dinge sehr dringend
Artilleriemunition habe ich schon
erwähnt aber Nachschub bei
Präzisionswaffen mit hohen Reichweiten
gehört eben auch dazu die von den
Franzosen gelieferten skypej und von den
Britten gelieferten
stormshadow sind nur noch in begrenzter
Stückzahl vorhanden Taurus würde hier
vor allenen den Zweck erfüllen dass man
das was man bisher damit gemacht hat mit
diesen Marl Körpern dann weiter mit
Taurus machen könnte und auch bei den
attackem die die Ukraine bisher bekommen
hat also diese Land Strecken also diese
mit höheren Reichweiten versehenden
Raketen aus den USA gibt es nur
begrenzte Stückzahlen also da wär Taurus
ganz sicher wichtig und am Ende muss man
sich ja nichts vormachen man wird gegen
die Russen im Süden der Ukraine sich nur
durchsetzen können wenn man die Logistik
tatsächlich behindert und dafür muss man
die Brücken zur Krim zerstören können
und Taurus könnte das
und deswegen sollte man der Ukraine das
auch zur Verfügung stellen vor allen
Dingen sollte man nicht lange
diskutieren und ewig warten und zög wenn
man es am Ende dann doch macht das
kostet nur für die Ukraine verletzte
Verwundete und auch gefallene mhm wir
sehen hier gerade eingeblendet eine
Karte auch mit den frontverläufen wie
sie sich verändert haben in den letzten
Monaten und da stellt man ja vor allem
zuletzt fest herlange dass sich so viel
nicht tut ich habe es ja auch eingangs
gesagt es gibt keine großen
Geländegewinne weder für die eine noch
die andere Seite wie bewerten Sie die
Lage ganz aktuell an der
Front
die Karte ist hilfreich und immer wieder
auf die Karte zu schauen ist auch
notwendig auch damit einem die
Entfernung klar werden und damit man
weiß wofür die Waffensysteme eigentlich
gebraucht werden da sieht man ja diesen
Küstenstreifen im Süden und wenn man die
Präzisionswaffen hat um da im Süden die
russischen Truppen wirklich komplett
unter Druck zu setzen wenn sie
nirgendwohin ihre gefechtsstände ihre
Truppenkonzentrationen ihre
führungseinrichtung ihre
Verteidigungsstellung wegbewegen können
in diesem südlichen Küstenstreifen dann
kommt die Ukraine eine bessere Situation
deswegen werden attackem Taurus und
andere Präzisionswaffen gebraucht aber
niemand will ja damit Russland angreifen
das kann man mit so einem Blick auf die
Karte glaube ich ganz gut erkennen worum
es wirklich geht man kann aber aus den
frontverläufen jetzt nicht alles
schlussfolgern also die
abnutzungsrate die Zerstörung z.B von
russischer Artillerie in dem von
Russland besetzten Gebiet bieten das ist
etwas das die Ukraine sehr systematisch
betreibt und wo sie auch Fortschritte
gemacht hat auf der Westseite der Krim
die Zerstörung von
luftverteidigungssystemen und radaren
ganz wichtiger Erfolg der ukrainischen
Gegenoffensive also das sind ja alles
Dinge die kann man auf der Karte nicht
erkennen und die Zerstörung der Logistik
im Süden die bildet sich auf der Karte
zunächst nicht ab aber wenn die
russischen Truppen nicht mehr versorgt
werden können dann wird sich das zu
einem späteren Zeitpunkt erst
materialisieren also man darf sich das
nicht so vorstellen wie ein Tauziehen wo
es immer nur hin und her geht an der
Frontlinie da passieren auch im
Hinterland sehr wichtige Dinge die dann
vielleicht erst sich später abbilden ein
Usern namens Timo fragt sind wir im
Westen mit der Produktion an Waffen am
Höchststand oder fährt die Produktion
erst noch
hoch ja wenn man zynisch wäre könnte man
sagen weder noch
m also wir lassten die Kapazitäten nicht
aus und gleichzeitig bauen wir auch
keine neuen auf und ich verstehe das so
langsam auch nicht mehr warum wir das
nicht machen ähm dieser Krieg dauert
bereits schon lange die industriellen
Fragen werden immer wichtiger und
munitionsproduktion für die Ukraine und
auch für uns selbst ist eine sehr
entscheidende Frage und im Moment guckt
Putin sich das an sieht dass wir nicht
das Notwendige tun und denkt sich na
dann habe ich vielleicht doch noch eine
Chance mich durchzusetzen ich find es
fast schon peinlich dass die führenden
Industrienationen in Europa nicht in der
Lage sind wirklich die Kapazitäten zu
erhöhen und mehr z.B Artilleriemunition
herzustellen als ein von Sanktionen
belegtes und wirtschaftlich doch
rückständiges Russland dieselbe Frage
stellt sich ein usernens cobretti auch
wieso sträubt sich der Westen vor großen
Waffen Waffenlieferungen die
entscheidend sein könnten liegt es
vielleicht auch daran dass der Westen
noch nicht wirklich entschieden hat was
die eigentliche Strategie ist und was
das eigentliche Ziel ist was man
verfolgt ja ich glaube dass das eine
sehr gute Frage ist die einen wichtigen
Kern trifft mir scheint weder innerhalb
der Bundesregierung noch zwischen den
Partnern der Ukraine die sie
unterstützen aus Europa noch
transatlantisch hat man wirklich geklärt
was ist das Ziel unserer militärischen
Unterstützung für die Ukraine also
wollen wir ein bisschen solidarisch sein
weil die Ukraine angegriffen wurde oder
ist das eine Frage die für unsere eigene
Sicherheit relevant ist wovon ich
überzeugt bin und tun wir dann auch
alles um dieses Ziel zu erreichen
nämlich unsere eigene Sicherheit zu
schützen und die internationale Ordnung
wiederherzustellen und auch klar
zumachen dass bei einem Angriffskrieg
der Angreifer keinen Gewinn haben darf
es wirkt so ein bisschen unentschlossen
wir machen ein bisschen mit wir helfen
bisschen es wäre einfacher auch zu
entscheiden welche Ressourcen eigentlich
gebraucht werden wenn man ganz klar
formuliert was ist das gemeinsame Ziel
die Ukrainer haben das für sich klar
festgelegt sie wollen die Grenzen von
1991 da wollen sie die Kontrolle wieder
haben und die Russen dort vertreiben und
viele Staaten in Europa die
mittelosteuropäer die Polen die
baltischen Staaten die Skandinavier aber
auch die Briten die haben auch ganz klar
dieses Ziel wir sagen immer nur wir
helfen der Ukraine solange das notwendig
ist und ich befürchte diese Zielstellung
ist leider das Rezept für einen sehr
langen Krieg der vor allen Dingen sehr
hohe Kosten bei der Ukraine verursacht
vielen Dank Nico lange für den Moment
wir kommen gleich wieder zu Ihnen zurück
wollen aber erstmal in die Länder
schauen zu unserem Korrespondenten in
Moskau Armin Körper und zu Tim Kröger in
harkiv an beiden Orten ist es sehr kalt
danke dass ihr hier im Stream die Fragen
auch der Userinnen und User beantwortet
Tim lass uns mal mit dir anfangen wir
haben das gerade angesprochen die
Unterstützung geht zurück und auch beim
wichtigsten Unterstützer den USA von
dort kommen schlechte Nachrichten für
die Ukraine die Republikaner haben
gerade ein Milliarden schweres hilfs
Hilfspaket blockiert ein User auf
Facebook fragt was würde passieren wenn
die Ukraine wegen fehlender Lieferungen
aufgeben
müsste also das ist natürlich im Moment
noch unvorstellbar aus ukrainischer
Sicht
ich habe den Eindruck dass die
ukrainische Seite und auch viele
Soldaten mit denen wir hier gesprochen
haben absolut dazu entschlossen sind
dass sie sich gegen die russische
Aggression verteidigen an so etwas wie
was wirklich passieren müsste wenn die
Ukraine aufgeben müsste ähm denkt hier
im Moment noch niemand dann schauen wir
nach Moskau zu Armin Körper dort war
Vladimir Putin in internationalen
Gesprächen sowohl heute als auch gestern
wie stellt sich denn die Lage aus
russischer Sicht im Moment
da also aus Russland beobachtet man
natürlich sehr genau was da in der
Ukraine passiert die Probleme innerhalb
der ukrainischen Führung und die
Widersprüche das wird hier natürlich
genüsslich kommentiert ganz genauso auch
die sich ausbreitende Kriegsmüdigkeit im
Westen man beobachtet natürlich genau
den Zuwachs der AFD in Deutschland in
Meinungsumfragen und die Wahlergebnisse
z.B in den Niederlanden und Slowenien
Präsident Putin hat sein Volk auf einen
langen Krieg eingeschworen und er glaubt
dass er den längeren Atem hat er glaubt
dass er das länger durchhält als der
Westen heute hat man aus dem innercirkel
des Kremmel anen historischen Vergleich
gehört die Ukraine könne für die USA ein
zweites Vietnam werden denn auch was da
in Amerika passiert wieder um den
Haushalt gerungen wird das wird hier
natürlich genau
beobachtet ich habe es angesprochen
putin war gerade unterwegs hat eine
Reise nach Saudi-Arabien in die
Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate
unternommen heute ist der iranische
Präsident raisi zu GOST zu Gast in
Moskau also eine große internationale
Bühne auf der sich Putin ganz offenbar
wohlfühlt hier sehen wir auch noch mal
die Bilder heute aus Moskau inwiefern
versucht Putin damit international zu
punkten na Putin versucht in allererster
Hinsicht mal nach innen zu punkten er
ist drei Monate vor der
Präsidentschaftswahl er will zeigen
business as usual er will zeigen trotz
der Sanktionen trotz der Versuche des
Westens ihn zu isolieren und auch trotz
des internationalen Haftbefehls wird er
mit Pomp empfangen auf der Welt und er
ist auf der diplomatischen Bühne
interessant ist es wird natürlich immer
um über Handel diskutiert bei diesen
Gesprächen und besuchen Russland braucht
neue Handelspartner es braucht Rohstoffe
es braucht Teile für die Wirtschaft
es wurde heute veröffentlicht hat der
Kremmel veröffentlicht dass gestern in
Saudi-Arabien eine gemeinsame Erklärung
abgegeben wurde dass man auch die
militärische Zusammenarbeit ausbauen
wolle Putin hat heute bei einem
Investorenforum über die Zusammenarbeit
mit China gesprochen dass auch da da die
Kooperation wirtschaftlich ausgebaut
würde auch militärisch und ich denke er
hat das in den Gesprächen mit dem Iran
zumindest nach außen nicht offen erklärt
aber wir alle wissen der Iran ist ein
wichtiger drohnenlieferant und auch da
wird von wirtschaftlicher Zusammenarbeit
die man ausbauen will gesprochen
m wir gehen noch mal zu Tim Kröger in
die Ukraine denn du hast es gerade
angesprochen man Armin man beobachtet in
Russland relativ genüsslich wie die
innenpolitischen Querelen in der Ukraine
laufen ein User schreibt hier selenski
hat Krach mit seinem general
Tim damit spielt er an auf den
Oberkommandierenden der Streitkräfte
Valerie saluschni der von einer
patsituation im Krieg und von einer
Sackgasse gesprochen hat und hier in
Deutschland ist vor allem auch sehr
wahrgenommen worden der Bürgermeister
von Kiev Klitschko der auch seinen
Präsidenten ungewöhnlich scharf gegangen
ist ähm welche Rolle spielt das in der
Ukraine also ich meine Klitschko ist
natürlich auch hier in der Ukraine ein
bekannter Mann auch ein populärer Mann
er ist wie du gesagt hast der
Bürgermeister von der Hauptstadt kieev
aber er ist halt eben auch ein schon
bekannter Rivale von Präsident selenski
das heißt die beiden sind aus
verschiedenen politischen Lagern sie
sind sich politisch nicht grün und es
ist auch nicht das erste Mal dass sie
sich gegenseitig ähm kritisiert haben
insofern würde ich jetzt diesen Streit
oder auch die Kritik die Klitschko an
selenski
geübt hat nämlich er habe vor dem Krieg
vor der russischen Aggression nicht
ausreichend gewarnt er habe das Land
nicht ausreichend vorbereitet jetzt
erstmal würde ich diese Kritik nicht zu
hoch hängen viel wichtiger ist
tatsächlich das was der Armeechef
salusni hier vor zwei Monaten gegenüber
einer Zeitung gesagt hat nämlich dass es
diese psituation gibt und vor allem eben
dass der ukrainische Präsident selenski
das dann danach zurecht gerückt hat aus
seiner Sicht den widersprochenheit
spricht die beiden waren sich ganz
offenbar in dieser Situation nicht einig
und das ist natürlich wirklich
entscheidend in der jetzigen Situation
wo es ja auch auf dem Schlachtfeld an
den Frontlinien für die Ukraine immer
schwieriger wird dass ich eben genau
diese beiden der Präsident und der
Armeechef einig sind ich denke das ist
wichtiger das muss man genauer
beobachten Tim wir hören Alarm im
Hintergrund ich gehe ganz sicher davon
aus wenn ihr in Gefahr seid als Team
dann die Schalter ab ne ansonsten würde
ich dir jetzt noch eine letzte Frage
stellen wie ist denn die Moral unter den
ukrainischen
Soldaten also wir haben verschiedene
Sachen gehört wir haben ja in den
vergangenen Tagen immer mal wieder mit
ukrainischen Soldaten sprechen können
sie sagen uns auf der einen Seite sind
Sie motiviert auf der anderen Seite aber
sind sie nach fast zwei Jahren Krieg
mittlerweile wirklich sehr erschöpft
auch die Familien der Soldaten sind
erschöpft das liegt vor allem daran dass
dass die Soldaten nur eine ganz geringe
Rotation haben das heißt sie kommen
wirklich nur sehr selten nach Hause
können ihre Familien können ihre Kinder
sehen das nagt natürlich an den Soldaten
das hat mittlerweile auch dazu geführt
dass es hier eine kleinere Bewegung von
Soldaten Ehefrauen gibt die fordern dass
es eine sogenannte Demobilisierung gibt
also dass
Soldaten wirklich nur für eine begrenzte
Zeit kämpfen dürfen die reden da von
anderthalb Jahren das ist ja
mittlerweile bei vielen die sich direkt
nach dem 24 Februar freiwillig gemeldet
haben schon überschritten also sie
wollen sozusagen dass nach einer
gewissen Zeit die Soldaten nach Hause
kommen eben weil die psychische die
physische Belastung mittlerweile
wirklich zu groß wird aber wie gesagt
wir haben auch Soldaten gehört die
gesagt haben trotz dieser Erschöpfung
die wir verspüren sind wir immer noch
motiviert
wir haben beispielsweise vor einigen
Tagen hier in einem medizinischen
stabilisierungspunkt hinter der Stadt
afdfka die ein rennpunkt an der Front
derzeit ist wo wirklich heftig gekämpft
wird dort haben wir mit verletzten
Soldaten gesprochen die haben uns gesagt
dass gerade in afdka die russischen
Streitkräfte die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte mit einer Angriffswelle
nach der anderen überziehen und dass das
wirklich unendlich erschöpfend und
ermüdend ist und dass es wirklich schwer
ist noch die Kraft zusammeln weiter zu
kämpfen wie gesagt das gilt nicht für
alle Frontabschnitte das gilt auch
längst nicht für alle Soldaten aber es
gibt mittlerweile diese Erschöpfung
vielen Dank Tim Kröger dann können wir
dich vielleicht an dieser Stelle dann
auch schon verabschieden und noch eine
Frage an Armin Körper in Moskau stellen
viele Userinnen und User fragen sich was
es mit dieser Sache auf sich hat es
wurde gemeldet und die Ukraine hat sich
auch dazu bekannt dass
nah Moskau ein ukrainischer Politiker
getötet wurde
ein ukrainischer
proussischer Politiker und das
interessiert hier viele User inwiefern
das in Russland aufgenommen
wird
genau der Mann heißt Ilia Kia der war
ein ukrainischer Politiker und hat in
Russland um Asyl gebeten weil er ja
proussisch sich in der Ukraine geäußert
hat und auch verurteilt wurde dort in
Abwesenheit der Mann wurde gestern tot
aufgefunden die Ukraine hat sich
offiziell dazu bekannt Russland nennt
das ein Akt von
Staatsterrorismus das ist natürlich eine
interessante Formulierung in dem Kontext
was natürlich das itende daran ist wenn
die Ukraine da wirklich dahinter steckt
und das behauptet sie ja dann ist es ihr
immerhin gelungen dass sich die
Bevölkerung in Russland doch jetzt
zumindest im Teilen verunsichert fühlt
dass man nicht mehr das Gefühl hat dass
der Präsident Putin der ist der
Sicherheit und Wohlstand garantiert und
das ist natürlich auch jetzt in der
Präsidentschaft im
Präsidentschaftswahlkampf für Präsident
Putin schon eine entscheidende schlappe
dass sowas in seinem Land passieren kann
vielen Dank Armin Körper für diese
Einschätzungen nach
Moskau und dann beschäftigen wir uns
hier wieder gleich mit Nico lange mit
einer Frage die auch viele Userinnen und
User umtreibt nämlich wie Drohnen in
diesem Krieg eingesetzt werden und dazu
hat Jochen Spieß einige Dinge mal
erklärt Drohnen erfüllen
unterschiedliche Aufgaben die
ferngesteuerten Fluggeräte überwachen
die eigenen Frontlinien oder die
Umgebung
genauso speren Soldaten mit ihnen
gegnerische Stellungen aus dazu dienen
auch Infrarot Kameras an Bord zudem
werden Drohnen zum zerstören und
gezielten töten eingesetzt ausgestattet
mit Sprengstoff die ausgespärten Ziele
werden genau angesteuert ohne Munition
zu vergeuden Drohnen sind flexibler und
billiger als Raketen dazu schwerer vom
Radar zu erfassen ein großer Nachteil
hingegen besteht darin dass sie sich
öfter durch ihre Fluggeräusche
verraten es gibt sehr unterschiedliche
Modelle große militärdrohen fliegen
viele hundert Kilometer weit und sind
stundenlang im Einsatz deren Ziele
können militärische Anlagen sein aber
auch Großstädte wie häufig in der
Ukraine im Schwarzen Meer nahe der Krim
werden immer wieder ukrainische
marinedrohnen eingesetzt ferngesteuerte
Boote die schon an russischen
Kriegsschiffen explodierten die
Beschädigung der krimbrücke soll ebenso
mit drohen
dazu kommt eine Vielzahl drohen die eine
Reichweite von unter 100 bis 300 km
besitzen mit kurzer Einsatzzeit sie
tauchen eher an den Frontlinien auf
ganze Schwärme von drohen können
großflächiger
agieren auf beiden Seiten werden
zusätzlich besonders wendige Drohnen
eingesetzt die auch bewaffnet und
teilweise mit Hilfe einer virtuellen
Brille gesteuert
werden die Ukraine ist mittlerweile
selbst z exptin im Herstellen von drohen
geworden dazu kommen Lieferungen aus den
USA und der Türkei Russland startete in
den Krieg mit 2000 eigenen drohen und
profitiert von Importen aus China und
Iran gegnerische Störsender und Hacker
können die Drohnen fehlleiten unter
Umständen sogar die versteckten
drohnenpiloten im Hintergrund Orten und
angreifen ja und genau dazu gibt es hier
viele Fragen im Chat die ich direkt
gerne an Nico lange weitergebe über
Youtube erreicht uns die Frage genau
dazu günstige Wirkmittel zur
drohnenabwehr sind oft wenig effektiv
gegen die russische Orlan 10 oder Sirius
Drohne ich hoffe ich habe das richtig
ausgesprochen wie kann man die Ukraine
hier
unterstützen ja die Abwehr von drohen
ist tatsächlich ein wichtiges Thema
geworden weil die russische Seite sehr
viel gelernt hat und auch die
Massenproduktion von den drohen mit
denen sie aus russischer sichicht gute
Erfahrung gemacht hat hochgefahren hat
und die erwähnten Oran und und Sirius
gehören sicherlich dazu auch die landet
kamikaz drrohne ist auf russischer Seite
sehr sehr wirksam äh die Ukraine braucht
Möglichkeiten diese Drohnen abzuwehren
vor allen Dingen mit elektronischer
Kampfführung das wirft aber für Partner
der Ukraine ein Dilemma auf weil in
dieser Technologie viele Geheimnisse
drin stecken von denen z.B die
Amerikaner nicht wollen dass die Russen
und vor allen die Chinesen das Lernen
wenn die auf dem Schlachtfeld in der
Ukraine auftauchen
man wird aber diese drohen nicht mit
teuren
flugabwehrsystemen bekämpfen können ähm
es gibt vor allen Dingen auch
Notwendigkeit vernünftige Radare zu
haben die diese Drohnen auch Orten
können die die sind technologisch
verfügbar und ein ganz interessanter
Ansatz ist ja in Washington besprochen
worden gerade gestern und heute wo ein
Verteidigungsindustrie Forum stattfindet
nämlich dass man Legacy Systeme also im
Grunde alte sowjetische Modelle
ukrainische Modelle aufrüsten kann mit
moderner Flugabwehr und mit vor allen
Dingen mit modernen radaren um gegen
drohen zu wirken das ist jetzt ganz
wichtig auch die gelieferten Kampfpanzer
und Schützenpanzer die wir geliefert
haben gegen Drohnen abzusichern weil das
sehr fatal wäre wenn die von billigen
drohen angegriffen werden können also es
gibt Möglichkeiten aber da müssen die
Partner der Ukraine mehr liefern und ich
glaube viel Potenzial liegt darin mit
der Ukraine gemeinsam diese Dinge in der
Ukraine herzustellen und dann
einzusetzen das heißt sie würden die
Frage von Sabine Kremer mit Ja
beantworten kann man bereits sagen dass
die von der Ukraine eingesetzten Drohnen
einen positiven Einfluss auf die
Kriegsführung hatten ja die drohen haben
die Ukraine gerettet ähm und auch die
schnelle Nutzbarmachung von drohen auf
der ukrainischen Seite haben für die
Ukraine viel Positives bewirkt die
Ukraine hat den drohenkampf und den
Einsatz von drohen im Krieg
revolutioniert auch weil sie in der Lage
waren die Daten von den drohen
zusammenzuführen und
auszuwerten dadurch die Russen zu
bekämpfen und jetzt ist es ja so dass
niemand mehr was macht ohne drohen die
Ukraine hat auch immer noch eine
Überlegenheit und ein Vorsprung bei
drohen Russland holt allerdings auf und
produziert viel soass jetzt die
entscheidende Frage sein wird bekommt
die Ukraine eigentlich die Komonenten
die man braucht um die drohen in der
Ukraine zu bauen und auch da sind wir
gefragt da ist auch eine Institution wie
die EU gefragt damit diese Drohnen da
ankommen und das ist nicht gefragt
worden aber das beantworte ich trotzdem
was ich sehr peinlich finde und womit
man sich beschäftigen muss ist dass so
viele Bauteile aus den USA aber auch aus
Deutschland aus anderen westlichen
Staaten in russischen drohen gefunden
werden die in der Ukraine eingesetzt
werden also da schießen wir uns ja
selbst ins Knie wenn wir versuchen der
Ukraine zu helfen und gleichzeitig aber
mit unserer Technologie die Ukraine
angegriffen wird mhm
ähm viele Userinnen und User diskutieren
hier in den Chats auch untereinander und
an einem kurzen Dialog möchte ich sie
gerne teilhaben lassen mit der Bitte um
eine abschließende Einschätzung sie
haben es auch schon mal angerissen
ein User fragt kann der Krieg überhaupt
noch von irgendeiner Seite gewonnen
werden und darauf antwortet ein anderer
User klar wenn die Ukraine endlich
angemessen Material bekäme kann der
Krieg sogar sehr schnell gewonnen
werden also man muss ja zunächst mal
definieren was heißt eigentlich gewinnen
das wird immer so in den Raum gestellt
aber das ist ja weder auf der russischen
Seite klar definiert noch bei uns was
wir eigentlich meinen mit die Ukraine
soll gewinnen aber ich teile die
Auffassung des Users dass das Ziel die
russischen Streitkräfte zu schlagen im
Süden der Ukraine und die russischen
Streitkräfte aus deruk inne
rauszudrängen dass dieses Ziel
militärisch erreichbar ist es will ja
niemand nach Moskau marschieren oder
Russland einnehmen das wird oft
verwechselt in der Debatte und das ist
ja eine Frage an uns was würden wir denn
benutzen um diese militärische Aufgabe
zu lösen um diese russischen Stellungen
zu durchbrechen um
im Süden der Ukraine z.B ans asofsche
mer
vorzustoßen und diese Dinge wenn wir die
Frage für uns beantwortet haben die
sollten wir der Ukraine lief
das ist ein militärisches Problem das
lösbar ist aber wir sollten der Ukraine
nicht viel weniger und viel langsamer
Dinge liefern und dann hoffen dass auf
diese Weise das Problem gelöst werden
kann das ist ein Stück weit unehrlich
was wir da
machen sagt der Militärexperte Nico
lange vielen Dank dass Sie bei uns in
der Sendung waren
gerne und ich möchte mich gerne
verabschieden mit einem Kommentar von
einer Userin namens Nina nenko sie
schreibt vielen Dank für Ihre Sendung
und die Einschätzung von Herrn Lange es
muss viel mehr passieren zur
Verteidigung der europäischen Werte
vielen Dank für diesen Kommentar und die
vielen anderen und bis zum nächsten Mal
[Musik]
tschüss